this year so he'll try to
get the a's a w in game two of the
series 17
start and yes he has been outstanding
for the club eight wins
on the season as isaiah kinder fell for
steps in the batter's box
there's a big slow curveball from chris
bassett
so the first time he shows it tonight he
gets the strikeout so now brock holt
he'll be the d.h tonight
swung on a ground ball up the middle
back a second elvis gliding to his left
has
it and throws to first and holders out
six three
and quickly two away and that'll bring
up adolesce garcia he's going on a
ground ball weakly to short rights elvis
he has it
he throws in passive has the one two
three top of the first with the a's
coming up in the bottom half
the lefty from orange county colby
allard allard two and three and a three
three three era 16th appearance and
sixth
start for the rangers this year laureato
facing colby
eighth pitch of the at-bat and lorianno
swings and misses strike three
so a strikeout for allard to get the
knight started
that'll bring up elvis who's bounding
226.
and that one out to right field gallow
several steps to his right makes the
play
that's two up two down and here is matt
olsen
over before yesterday the big lefty
hitting 292.
that's popped up short left field in and
toward the line drifts eli white still
moving toward the line he reaches up and
pulls it down
one two three inning for allard and
that'll bring up nate lowe's batting 257
10 home runs and 40 runs batted in 3-2
pitch swinging in the miss on a high
fastball
second strikeout for chris bassett it's
going to be up to eli
white and white swings and misses on a
fast ball away and down he goes
so it's a one two three second for
bassett with two strikeouts
kobe allard against matt chapman chapman
riding a 16-game hitting streak
homeward in the first inning yesterday a
little bit outside and chapman has to
lead off
denise had their first base runner
pinders coming up rounded through
base it right field chapman glances back
at gallo and decides to stay at second
base first and second nobody out
then lowry coming up hitting 375
with some power and he pops this one up
first base side a lot of room out there
in foul ground gallow wants it and he'll
grab it
and now hustles it back toward the
infield
chapman tags and moves to third that's a
gutsy
running move by chapman when he does
advance
on the foul eye and with runners at
first and third and one out now
shawn murphy will be the hitter and now
he can get a run with flymo
right over white's got it
chapman's gonna come in to score and the
a's take a one-nothing lead so
good solid baseball by the ace here's
the a's debut of frank schwendell
tall right-handed hitter he had 15 major
league at bats
frank gets it to deep left field in the
corner if it's fair it's gone
right down the line and gone
in his first athletics at bet a towering
home run
down the left field line what a debut
and it's three-nothing a's over the
rangers in the bottom of the second so
the a's with a three-nothing lead for
chris bassett
and there's one away and here comes nick
solac
swinging in a miss four strikeouts for
chris bassett
all swinging well three out of four have
been on that good fastball chris bassett
is just
losing confidence these days basketball
swing and a miss a power sinker down it
in
finishes off connor falefa and the
rangers in the third
so that's three in a row set down since
the ibanya is single in the third inning
the only batter to reach so far for
texas
and now here's joey gallo curveball
swinging and a miss
dropped right off the table at 73 miles
an hour
bassett finishes off gallow and the
rangers in the fourth
a half a dozen k's so far for bassett
just one hit for the rangers that was
the two out single by
the ninth place here bonnie is in the
third inning with this ball
well hit out to left field and that one
will
one hop the wall pinder on a bare hand
hustles it back but
eli with an easy one-out double so
here's jonah heim runner and scoring
position for the first time
for texas a little pop-up
right to chapman and that's the second
half
that'll bring up nick chris kicks and
here's the delivery and that's swung on
a broken back comeback a right to pass
it
underhand flipped it first for the white
left at second great job by bassett as
usual
kobe allard had 72 pitches averaging 18
pitches per inning so far today that's a
little bit high
just had that one hiccup the three runs
on the second inning and there's another
strikeout
back-to-back strikeouts
andrews chase strike three two
strikeouts in the inning
for allard we've got two on one out with
lots of power coming up
elise garcia will be first and then
gallow balls bounced
up the middle lowry's got it laurie's
gonna flip to elvis anders throw to
first he's not in top
these do get it out at second base and
here comes the booming bat at joey gallo
as the tying run with
two outs here in the sixth and the a's
leading three nothing
the pitch is swinging and bounced at
first near the bag right to olson
he goes to the back for the out and a
great job by passive
he wins the battle with joey gallo
there's bassett
after what was a long top of the six he
had to work hard got out of that jam
and then quickly back out there through
the top of the seventh
hits this one well to center field
lorianno's back
lorianno times his lead he doesn't have
to as he grabs it right at the base of
the wall
chris bassett his knight is probably
done
and he is terrific once again as he
leaves
with a three-nothing lead so he's going
for the shutout leading three to nothing
and they have the
closer lou trevino to the mouth so good
way to face joey gallo with nobody
aboard
dallow over three lately that's been a
rarity to keep him that quiet
gallow gets his ball hard deep out to
right and that one's gone
oh my he's done it again and now has six
home runs in the last four games
so the tying runs are on base and now
the
the former oakland a jonah heim
right there on the inside corner strike
three call
so a perfect pitch by lou trevino
solac is coming up the rangers last hope
so i'm gonna fly ball popped into right
sky bullet coming on he's right there
and he makes the catch and these get a
good win
and a tough ninth inning and a tough
save for lou trevino
the centerpiece tonight the first major
league home run
in his first game as an athletic by
frank schwendell